pasadas las nueve de la mañana de este
sábado ocurrió un accidente en el
sistema de transporte colectivo metro de
la Ciudad de México en la línea 3 entre
las estaciones Potrero y la raza en
dirección a Indios Verdes hacia el norte
de la ciudad hubo un choque de trenes
que ha dejado hasta el momento de manera
oficial un saldo de una persona
fallecida mientras que 35 personas han
sido trasladadas en ambulancias a
distintos hospitales de la Ciudad de
México pues sus lesiones requieren
atención médica la jefa de gobierno de
la ciudad Claudia sheinbaum no se
encontraba en la capital del país al
momento del accidente ella estaba por
iniciar un acto político en el Estado de
Michoacán al saber de la situación se
regresó vía aérea a la ciudad para dar
seguimiento a las investigaciones
peritos de la Fiscalía de la Ciudad de
México ya se encuentran trabajando para
determinar la causa exacta de este
accidente el presidente Andrés Manuel
López Obrador vía Twitter ha expresado
sus condolencias por la persona que el
momento ha perdido la vida y se mantiene
atento al seguimiento de esta situación
sobre todo por la salud de los de los
heridos que están insisto siendo
atendidos en distintas clínicas de
hospitales de la capital del país